well you know oil is just one part of
the energy picture it's not it's not the
whole picture we just happen to see it
most clearly because we use it in our
cars but again when you turn on that
light switch there's very little oil in
that equation at all that's coming from
a lot of other sources so I'm not sure
the oil she'd be picked out is the only
one I'm not sure anybody has a right to
anything in life I think we we have we
have I guess the right we have the right
to work hard and hope that we get
blessed with the right answers but but I
think we've got to act responsibly I
think we've got to work for it I don't
think it's going to be dropped from
heaven and I some people think that some
of these new technologies can be dropped
from heaven i guess i don't i don't
believe that i'm a scientist and i
believe in science and i believe in
science being patient and that science
being anticipated this is not something
like you're trying to go to the moon or
develop a atomic weapon this is a
multi-element complex model of various
energy sources that has a huge
infrastructure in place this is not like
starting over from scratch and saying
you can just create something out of
nothing and that's where people miss it
is to recreate the infrastructure that
we have to think that a technology like
the combustion engine could actually
last in today's world for over a hundred
years why is that possible it's just
because it happens to be a phenomenal
technology now what the next one is
going to be I don't know we got to be
working on it and we should put a lot of
money behind it but putting 30 billion
behind it's not going to change the
answer more input in 50 billion 50
million behind it probable again the
right people focused on